So in 2000 I started
a company called Glare Soft.
And Glare Soft was interesting because
right around then personal computers
were becoming powerful enough to sort of
replace what you would go to a recording
studio to use as a musician.
And so, a handful of us around the world
started these small tiny software
companies, building this pioneering
technology that actually could
replace some analog synthesizer in
your PC and we did that until 2006.
We sold the company to a larger
audio software company and
it was an amazing experience.
We grew a lot,
we sold a lot of products at one point
we were in Apple retail
which was super exciting.
Send my parents the to Apple store and
I wrote the software.
So yeah that was the company
that I created and
I'm still to this day
really proud of it.